looking for someone took because you say
you want a guy that puts you in the
check so like I'm your guy it depends
okay yo me and you me and you an item
right and you tell me Shut up and I'm
like don't you ever talk to me like you
shot that beat up how I feel because
that's me checking you
according to your
bubble guys checking is feminine why are
you why are you out here I'm just I'm
just asking women yeah
it's not going to get toxic if you're
like that and he's like that isn't it
it's going to get toxic isn't it just
going to become an argument wait wait
wait I'll prefer get that how about
feminine checking someone this is
feminine y'all here playing Tit for Tat
with women right no she's gonna say this
and then I'm gonna say this is going to
put no no no no no no pick your balls up
no no and walk out the room no no I
don't I don't engage him back and forth
with people it's not about that it's a
it's a form it's a it's a thin line of
this it's a thin line of respect
at the end of the day what you allow
will continue
if if a woman tells me to shut my mouth
I would tell her very quickly there and
then never let that happen again that's
it I won't tell her shut up because I
just gave him a scenario me checking her
is me telling her my boundaries right
that's right don't cross that boundary
again that's it simple that's not
checking that's just I'm proud of my
boundaries and if you're not going to
respect them I respect my boundaries and
if you don't respect my boundaries then
we're not compatible that just sounds
very feminine yeah no no no no no no I
like it I don't I don't know you I don't
know I don't know like you gotta let me
finish damn it's just the way the way
you're talking like like that sounds
like a woman like when you say oh I need
you to respect my boundaries like women
say that no it's usually after years of
therapy see what is it
you thought black woman as well when you
were talking before about how like an
unexpected women expect you not to speak
and Etc to me you sounded like a woman
you sound like a it's very interesting
you know what it is all right look I I'm
very sure of myself so your opinion is
your opinion I appreciate them do I
agree with them no
um what I will say though it's it's very
interesting to hear that opinion on your
personal I don't no no that's fine it's
fine listen listen if you know me you
know me if you don't know me then that's
good for you but one thing I will say is
anybody that's able to speak on their
points of views in terms of differences
situations that's them you can't bracket
it or pull it in a place that sounds
feminine so if I if I want to tell
someone respect my stuff I'll tell you
what I think this is a feminine strategy
right it's not really no no you use the
definition when when you when someone
says something that kind of like
contradicts you you change definitions
so now you've just said you can't gender
Behavior which is which is a women's
kind of strategy in in a debate well bro
I like what you're doing but I I find it
very interesting so it's it's very very
simple for me it's not about changing
the words it's not about that it's what
I believe
so men I'm allowed to okay so what
you're basically saying is if somebody
now comes to me and does something I
don't like it's feminine yeah no no no
no no here we are there's the problem
hold on hold on hold on it's feminine
for me to stand up and say don't do that
okay I just think it's like feminine to
argue back like I think like but in the
same way there's a difference between
women
look look I I like I like this because
it's all about opinions right I hate
what you're saying it is quite
is unmanly to argue with a woman right
back right but at the same time that
doesn't mean as a man you shouldn't be
able to tell somebody what your
expectations are
okay I think the thing is the more you
talk the more you sound like things I've
heard women say and I'm just we've been
that's interesting then I'll leave it
like that I'll leave it for the people
to decide can I can I just say something
I say if you're not allowed to say your
boundaries say you're in a relationship
and she's going at you but you can't say
excuse me then then isn't that a bit
domestic violence and is that is that
not what we're talking about please
don't be a victim now like no I don't
want to see you get that permanent I
don't want I don't want my man to be
like yeah I was a victim of something no
but do you do you do you see what I'm
saying if you're kind of making out
there him saying these are my boundaries
please respect them is feminine
everyone's going to have boundaries wait
so men not mentality boundaries no do
you know what it is
I'm interested I tell you what it is I
tell you what it is calm down every week
Weekly right and for me weekly for Pearl
like four days a week right we speak to
women on the show yeah and we have heard
repeated lines throughout this six seven
months that we've been doing this right
and one of them is respect my boundaries
is a very it's like a very feminine
thing to say so it's like when you hear
a man say it it's like this is the first
time I think I've heard a guy say that
okay cool so allow me to allow me to
because you like you've there's a
there's now context to it it's because
you've been hearing a certain pattern
from from women from women yeah so maybe
there's not enough men that's speaking
about I like the fact that we have
different opinions ourselves but me I I
take pride in respect I feel like that's
no I feel like that
I feel like what he's saying is key like
for a man and a woman to get along
there's boundaries and their principles
both men and women should have
boundaries and no one should cross the
boundaries once you've crossed the
boundaries the man has the right to
leave or the woman has the right to
leave do you go I mean you both have
boundaries in a relation [ __ ] I think
this is yeah all right let me let me
accurately Define
all the ways that was feminine exactly
why so I so firstly us men were physical
creatures in it women women engaged with
the world through through communication
because they're not as physical they're
not strong they can't assert themselves
physically yeah there's black boxing
yourself
from what you're saying why we say it
sounds like how a woman would speak is
you talking back asserting your
boundaries by basically talking back
which is essentially asking or trying to
tell someone is is very feminine because
a man I just I just assert my boundaries
I don't ask it's not a check checking
kind of thing another way that was
feminine is framing so I noticed when
you're talking about you experiences in
relationship you you framed it the way
you talk is like you are you were like a
victim of this woman and like you are
asked for permission you said stuff like
oh I wasn't allowed to do this you know
I wasn't allowed to do that she didn't
treat me like this that which sounds
like you're a victim of the situation
which is unlike a man because you can't
be a victim of a woman because I can
always choose where to spend my time on
energy so that that's where the complete
difference is that's normally a female
kind of talking Frankie pattern thank
you can I can I address that back yeah I
think it's quite sad that your
perspectives of communication between
one person to another person is defined
by sex
now
should I watch should I roll around with
like a caveman and throw my fists around
or should I ghost somebody without
telling them why I have the option
see I have an option
I have a choice I have free will I don't
follow no one's doctrines or principles
so you calling a family maybe you're the
feminine guy because you don't know how
to communicate sufficiently until some
of the boundaries listen I get it
correct what happened let me let me
finish let me finish I can get a
cracking anywhere else inside That's The
Power of free will
right if I decide I'm back to that
personal thing I give a bit of myself
because I'm confident now
talking on that situation I I said I
wasn't allowed doesn't mean I didn't do
I was just giving you an example of the
question that he asked I was given a
fair example and a justification and how
the knock-on effects from that
individual played a part of me I'm not
afraid to say yeah go on what would you
do in that situation if I got away to
shut up would you shot I would look at
her for about five to seven seconds
again that's femininity I'll give her an
opportunity to reconsider that course of
action
because girls holy look yeah I don't
need to I don't need to I used to do
this when I was younger every boy learns
this when you're younger like Mom used
to say stuff my sister used to say stuff
and I noticed if you start talking back
you get into this feminine state where
now you're both waffling and back and
forth arguing they don't respect you
they don't care what you're saying
anyway so as as men normally learn that
like the most important these situations
is not to start talking in it like I'll
let you decide and then if if you're
still being annoying and rude then you
know I'll just walk away and I don't ask
there was no permission and you have no
control over anything I do let me let me
see one of them and no one ever crosses
my boundaries
I think the best way to control silence
and taking away I hate that yeah
you know yeah because it drives you nuts
as well when a guy argues with you he's
giving you like the attention you want
let's try like if a guy just walks away
I think that's that's like torture and
this is what okay let me just let me
just say so I've been in like a few
long-term relationships right and this
is what I realized with the whole
quote-unquote boundary swing before
things even get there they're a
conversate for me there are
conversations that I had between the men
and the um woman and you kind of
I guess you flesh out what what type of
person you're with right and so I know
if
if you were saying if a woman told me to
shut up I know if she got to that point
which some would shut up she would have
known that was the wrong thing to do
anyway so like pal said that once or one
and also as you said she's helped me to
shut up I'm gonna look at you for a
while and be like
really it's awkward okay that's where
we're going and and the thing is my my
next response is not going to be the
response it's going to be yours because
the way I look at you you're gonna know
that you've done something wrong do you
know what I mean and then so for me it's
like we can either I'm not going to do
that back and forth and I could probably
I'll probably leave uh
no I I wouldn't I don't engage in
arguments with women like that okay I
don't yeah I don't I don't engage people
why this have to be classified as an
argument right see what I get what
you're saying the kind of the concept
you're putting in is arguments that
status like it's not it's a conversation
so all he could say is
don't talk to me like that conversation
ended
up at the same time at the same time I
get what you guys are saying and I'm
taking it I do understand where it comes
from and it's a it's a point of view
that one I respect it but what I would
say is that
there are times where people don't know
where they're going wrong regardless of
your the context of how long you've been
together or in the open discussion you
had in that moment in time
emotions from both sides are high people
say from my side fine you might be a
cool Collective character yeah not
everything not everything is always
going to be like that I'm not gonna lie
I'm a bit more stoic as well like when
it comes to like arguments like I'm kind
of more cool and calm and kind of chill
you should be yeah but at the same time
what if she now ask you where did I go
wrong are you not gonna have the
conversation she will never ask you that
you'd have to have these conversations
but there are some people that don't see
where they go wrong I think I think
you're convincing yourself that there's
a reason for this course of action and I
don't think it actually exists I don't
need to I don't I mean this is what
people do right you have you have these
back and forth conversations and a lot
of women will convince themselves that
like some question was asked and that's
why this this discussion or argument is
escalating and going to reason where it
is and you know you if you actually in
these situations have you heard a couple
fight argue like like aggressively and
it just drags on and on and if you
listen to them you're like this
conversation could have stopped like 30
minutes okay
no but you said my
let me give you something to think about
you say that your approach is to keep
smiling and walk away right
something like that okay something like
that so what happens you just pick up
where you left off
when you get back to talking no I just I
just carry on they will stop talking
hold on you say I'm gonna say it again
so you ghost or whatever you call it cut
the line cut all forms of communication
right and it gets awkward in the house
everyone hold on hold on so the silence
just however long it needs to be yeah so
when it the conversation starts again
are you just picking up from where you
left off before the situation no
so what happens
I come back and well depending on
whether that the conversation was based
on a point where she making a point was
I making a point what's the country but
what is it why does that not have to be
like what you're now making excuses for
no it's not an excuse me it is because
your doctrines was I cut the
conversation there's no context because
when I gave you a story communication
I'm gonna listen to you I just want I
just want to break something very very
great TV go on you said when when I was
talking I was trying to make it out like
a victim right
but you said bear in mind we've just had
a talk about domestic violence when when
you was talking about
um your boundaries you said men can't be
victims of women
and we and well an hour ago we was
talking about how domestic violence with
men is not taken seriously and you say
something like that
yeah
so I I saw your whole sorry a whole 15
30 minutes was a contradiction yeah 100
so so obviously in reality
um this is reality a woman can stop a
man Etc there's cases like that but I
generally believe a masculine man a
healthy masculine man with a strong
mindset cannot really it's there's very
few cases where a man like that can be a
victim of a woman because you always
have agency and power of yourself you're
never going to be the less dominant I'm
gonna adjust you what's what's your name
because I'm going to dress you with Alex
Alex you're nice to meet you man bro the
way you're talking like I got into this
lady about the way she was throwing
certain words and the blanket in the way
you're saying is a healthy healthy
listen men can be affected just like
anybody else through violence mental
other things don't be so naive and be so
strong-headed that you're not open to
other points of views that now it's a
case of a healthy man bro are you
telling me that when I was in that
situation I'm not a victim I wasn't
healthy
in your in your situation yeah because
what sounds unhealthy because you were a
victim I was not a victim I told you I
wasn't a victim you're the one that
blanketed it so so what are you so what
you're saying is so yeah I said no
framed it like you're a victim there's
no framing I told a story you took it
like that obviously how would you digest
certain things is up to you
yeah but you're saying something that's
self-evident okay I'm gonna ask you a
question did you take it like I was
playing a victim let's let's not follow
that I just want to ask you Jesus
reminds me of I was argue with myself no
no no no no we're not we're not arguing
we're having a discussion let's go back
to that initial conversation you said we
will go back to it but I'm asking a
question do you feel when I shake I'm
listen there's no right no wrong
actually this is great I'm not gonna
laugh I want to ask you a question do
you personally feel what I gave you a
scenario was that me trying to play a
victim
in a way I would say yeah
you didn't you didn't
State you may say you basically made you
the topic you never stated the other
woman's
you know her how she felt in this
situation or you know she's not here to
talk about it I'm talking about an
experience she wasn't here the question
is from I respect your pen and I'm gonna
take it that's fine but I just wanted to
ask a question and everybody's entitled
to the answer yeah I think right okay so
let's go back to that point where you
said a woman is rude to me
um you know she said me shut up shut up
Alex or whatever uh I I I kind of cut
the conversation short I come back
you're saying do I restart that
conversation Etc do you know do you
continue like nothing or continue from
yeah so do I restart it from where we
ended or you know go through another
path I asked I said well it depends on
what purpose the initial conversation
had if she brought something up and that
conversation was based on how she felt
then I think it's her responsibility to
restart the conversation because it's it
serves her if it was something I brought
up and I wanted to address then normally
I wouldn't I wouldn't I feel like the
disrespect is enough of an office
I get what he's saying I get what he's
saying but doesn't that doesn't sound
like more tactical oh she's the one
that's enrolled so I'm gonna allow her
to reunit if you wanna but that's how
logic works you know if someone has an
issue and we have a discussion and then
they're rude then I cut off that
conversation because I don't I don't
engage in rude and you know
disrespectful conversations if you still
want to meet that point then it's your
problem that's why you started the
conversations
that's not Tit for Tat I'm interested to
what I'm going to ask you why okay cool
I wouldn't classify myself a misogynist
but if I if I've got traits or I display
something that's fine each to their own
right what you're saying is fine and
that's your method of dealing you keep
on you keep on starting like you know
different experiences you you keep on
saying because I'm open to everybody's
opinion and you keep on saying things
that should be self-evident so this this
is a great example of how Society is now
feminizing men this idea that like we
men are encouraged to take on this
victim mantle and even start to speak
like women so that's the thing I hear a
lot of women say okay they'll be like
okay that's your opinion as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible